Jimmy thing from a game spot here at e3
2016 I'm here speaking with Frank azor
general manager of alienware and Frank
can you tell us what we're looking at
here so this is the world's first OLED
gaming notebook so this is a brand new
product that we just announced yesterday
and like I said it's OLED so I mean if
you look at the quality of this display
it's just amazing and the way we're able
to do that is with the OLED technology
the OLED benefits give us a contrast
ratio of one hundred thousand to one it
also gives us one hundred and four
percent color gamut and we get a sub 2
millisecond response time typically in
an LCD display especially in a notebook
one the best performance you're able to
get is about an eight millisecond
response time so that gives you a
crisper image less ghosting let's image
bleed especially during high action
games and movies the color gamut you can
see it's pretty clear here the Reds the
Greens they just pop out so beautifully
it almost looks like you're looking at a
3d display and part of that is because
of the blacks OLED has a huge advantage
in that it doesn't require backlighting
like LCD does so pretty much every
single pixel is an LED that can turn on
or off and by being able to turn it off
and not having to have it back lit you
can get real blacks blocks that are so
rich that they almost blend in with the
border around the display so this
product just went on sale today or
yesterday sorry and it's available for
1299 a really aggressive price
considering an oled TV or an oled
monitor out there typically two or 3x
more expensive than than with their LCD
equivalent so we're really proud of this
is the world's first and yeah like I
said it's available immediately can you
walk us through you know how it how
differs from you know how an LCD might
display an image so oh like I said every
single pixel can turn on or off and you
can't do that on LCD right now the
technology doesn't allow you to do that
so what folks are doing is you know the
way LCD is in a
backlit as we typically have edge LEDs
and then you have a back light panel
that you illuminate and then that is how
you get the light to come through some
premium TVs for example what they do is
they'll put white LEDs behind the LCD
display and then they turn them on or
off and they may have like 50 LEDs or
150 LEDs but nothing compares to the
millions of organic LEDs that you're
able to do here so the amount of detail
of where you can have black versus color
and everything it's just unrivaled with
an LCD display because of the inherent
technology advantages a tolit has jenna
i know right next to it you guys have
you know LCD and just looking at it in
person you know the blacks look much
darker on the OLED display and you know
it trumps even IPS displays as well this
is there's no better image quality right
now in a notebook than what this oled
displays offering it doesn't matter if
it's IP any technology out there on an
LCD it cannot compare to what we're
delivering with all that again because
of just the technologies inherit
advantages around the back the way it
back lights it the images and the color
gamut and then the motion blur we offer
some panels out there that have 104
percent color gamut for example that our
LCD panels but they don't have the
benefit of the deep blocks and they
can't get you the the response time that
the OLED technology offers do that
subdue millisecond response time 104
percent color came it does that mean a
four percent that there are four percent
more colors or can you sort of go clear
that up it's compared to Adobe's
specification that is just a little bit
better and then then though the one
hundred percent Adobe requirement that's
out there based not requirement but
though the specification that they've
defined so we can go we have a little
bit more color saturation than that
Adobe specification is it yeah I noticed
I was just like looking at the screen
here the greens the Greens look much
better on you know on the old I panel
you know right now a big buzz word when
it comes to display technology is is HDR
is this HDO or is it something different
how does it compare so there are some
specifications around HDR specifically
around the brightness that a panel needs
to be in order for it to be officially
HDR qualify
it this doesn't meet that requirement
this is about a 315 it panel and I
believe hgr calls for something hot way
higher than I think it's double that so
it's not official HDR for that reason
but as you can see I mean it's kind of
harder to it's hard to imagine a panel
brighter than this I mean you can see
the image and the quality and everything
of it is more than good enough out there
so I don't think that not meeting the
HDR specification is going to hurt
anybody's appeal for this product yeah
cool thank you Frank for more
information on III stay tuned to
gamespot com